escape from new york that's the focus of
tonight's angle
if there was ever a place in the united
states that stands as the supreme test
case for liberalism
it's new york
and tonight we can unequivocally say the
results are horrendous across the board
think about it the democrats are in
charge at every level of government
there not just in the mayor's office in
new york city but in albany the
democrats outnumber the republicans
there by 106 to 42
current conditions in new york are
solely the product of liberal rule
crime is out of control up in every
category except murder a 44 increase in
2022 alone
with repeat offenders a huge part of the
spiral
now to add insult to actual injury
governor hokul's new gargantuan budget
is filled with all the usual union
giveaways all to fund her re-election
bid
now as the wall street journal's
editorial board pointed out the 220
billion dollar deal's most egregious
earmark is 600 million dollars to help
ms hokel's hometown football team the
buffalo bills build a new stadium what a
wretched deal for taxpayers
now this proposal is double florida's
budget
new york's population is 19.8 million
florida's is
21.8 million
so who governs smarter again
now that's just all scratching the
surface of the fiscal corruption we're
seeing there's tax breaks for marijuana
businesses health care for illegals over
the age of 65 tax incentives for
hollywood filmmakers the list goes on
and on now there's a positive note
restaurants will be able to serve to go
drinks for the next three years
great but protecting the outdoor pub
crawls they're fun but it's not going to
keep people from fleeing new york
the extent of the exodus has been
shocking now between july 2020 and july
of last year more than 300 000 moved out
of new york state
and according to a poll by the
partnership for new york city forty
percent of employees who live in
manhattan are thinking of leaving
since the early days of the pandemic
moving trucks empty streets and
apartments seem to have become a staple
all across the five boroughs between
rising crime and homelessness a large
percentage of new yorkers who make up
the city's private sector workforce
think it may be best to leave is the
city going to be safe or are we going to
drift back into conditions where we just
can't be in the streets and the subway
the whole state is dying
in 1960 new york had 45 electoral votes
in 2024
it'll have only 28.
meanwhile over the same period florida
went from 10 electoral votes to 30.
now low tax tough on crime pro-freedom
states like florida and texas are
growing they're thriving
at some point waiting for it
the voters who are still left in new
york have to say to themselves we're
tired of this and we're not going to
take it anymore they blew their coveted
response with long lockdowns and
mandates we warned them that would be a
disaster it led to an acceleration of
families fleeing the public schools
through last fall enrollment in new york
city public schools dropped by 50 000
since the start of the pandemic
this is just this is insane it's
infuriating it's embarrassing
new york should be the creme de la creme
of our country
think about what it has that so many
other states don't have voters start to
have to wonder like how does a city
known as the financial capital of the
world
known for its theater in opera and how
does a state with such breathtaking
lakes natural resources one known for
its stunning beaches on long island it's
storied universities
how on earth
can this place be so screwed up
how on earth can the state be in such
decline
three words
far left democrats
for decades the voters thought it was a
good idea to turn its government over to
one family the cuomos
we know how that worked out
after andrew cuomo embroiled in scandal
was forced out in august
they installed kathy hulkel as governor
she's a complete hack she doesn't know
what she's doing
in fact she's so bad the guy she chose
last year to be her lieutenant governor
was just forced to resign this week
after being indicted on bribery and
fraud charges
today we announced that brian benjamin
the lieutenant governor of the state of
new york has been indicted for bribery
and related offenses
mr benjamin surrendered to law
enforcement this morning
it's been one bad leader
after another lately
new york became a laughingstock under
big bird de blasio with its pro-illegal
alien anti-police agenda
what was he known for he was known for
being his just lazy
and focused on important stuff like
painting black lives matter in front of
trump tower
the new mayor campaign though as a more
sensible alternative
eric adams but that was just a head fake
mr mayor what direction
is this city headed in terms of public
safety as you sit here this morning the
morning after a mass shooting is it
really getting better
we are going to get better this is going
to be a safe city but let's be clear
we're dealing with uh historical
inequalities historical abandonments and
failures
wait wasn't history didn't all of that
history exist before rudy giuliani
became governor mayor excuse me
now everything the left complains about
now
was true then and yet giuliani got crime
under control
this is not about history it is about
competence
now imagine if you'd moved to new york
let's say i don't know 15 years ago from
dominican republic
you saved up and started a small
business
played by the rules but now
you got teenagers trapped in rotten
schools
you lost your store during the
ridiculous lockdowns
and this week you're afraid to ride the
subway
imagine being that person now frank
sinatra famously saying i want to be a
part of it new york new york
but today you're not so much waking up
in a city that doesn't sleep you're
waking up in a city
that doesn't work anymore
with the governor's race though this
fall
this is the time for new yorkers to make
a brand new start of it
and it's up to you new york and that's
the angle hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else